واشهد ان لا اله الا الله وحده لا شريك له
واشهد ان محمدا عبده ورسوله اللهم صل وسلم
وبارك على نبينا محمد وعلى اله واصحابه
اجمعين اما بعد
يقول ابن القيم رحمه الله تعالى
في بلوغ النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
المدينه مهاجرا اليها
وفي بنائه مسجده المبارك عليه افضل الصلاه
واتم التسليم
والمؤاخاه التي قام بها بين اصحابه
المهاجرين والانصار
كان من المهم جدا في غايه الاهميه
ليس
ان يهاجر هو واصحابه الى المدينه فقط
بل كان لابد ان يستقبله
هو والانصار اصحابه من الانصار
استقبالا تاما
وان يجعل بين المهاجرين والانصار مؤاخاه
تفوق
الاخوه
والقرابه التي تكون بالدم
هذه اخوه اسلاميه شرعيه وقوه في الله
هذا الانسان يحب اخاه ليس لانه يكتسب منه
شيئا من الدنيا
وليس لانه يطمع في شيء في يده
وانما يحبه
لانه يظن ان الله يحبه
ومن غايه الحب يعني
الحب الحقيقي اذا الانسان حب
فانه يحب
من يحبه محبوبه
ويحب الله سبحانه وتعالى
ويحب من احب الله سبحانه وتعالى وهو يبغض
اعداء الله
وهو كذلك
يبغض من يبغضه الله سبحانه وتعالى هذه هي
علامه الحب الحقيقيه
ليست
المحبه مجرد القول او الزعم
بل المحبه في ما يقتضيه ذلك الحب فيما
يقتضيه ذلك الحب ذلك
هو الذي يجعل الحب
حقيقيا
او يجعل المحبه مجرد مقوله الله عز وجل
يذكر هذا المعنى فيقول قل ان كنتم تحبون
الله
فاتبعوني يحببكم الله
الانسان
اذا احب غيره
اذا احب شخصا
فان الغايه في ذلك ان يحبه محبوبه
كذلك اذا كان الانسان يحب الله حقا
فانه سيفعل كل ما في وسعه
لان
يكتسب محبه الله سبحانه وتعالى
فالنبي صلى الله عليه وسلم امر ان
يعلم الصحابه
ويعلم اتباعه هذا قل ان كنتم تحبون الله
فاتبعوني انظروا الى كيف
جاءت اللفظ
لم يقل
ان كنتم تحبون الله
فاتبعوا رسوله
ان كنتم
تحبوننا
فاتبعوا رسولنا او فاتبعوا رسولي او ما
شابه ذلك من الالفاظ كلها صحيحه لكن جاء
اللفظ كيف قل ان كنتم تحبون الله يعني جعل
النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم هو الذي يبلغ
عنه ذلك
فاتبعوني يحببكم الله
ويغفر لكم ذنوبكم فالنبي صلى الله عليه
وسلم حينما وصل الى المدينه كان في وسعه
ان ياخذ قطعه من الارض
وان يجعل هذه الارض
وما عليها من مباني او من بيوت او حجرات
وان يجعل المهاجرين في هذه الحاره سوي
حاره
والاراضي كثيره في المدينه مسوي حاره
ويبني عليها مباني ويخلي المهاجرين ياتوا
الى هذا هذه المباني لكن اذا كان ذلك ماذا
يكون في غايه الامر منتهى الامر
يبقى
المهاجرون
محجورون عن الانصار صح ولا لا تكون حاره
المهاجرين وهذول الانصار هذول المهاجرين
واحنا الانصار احنا وهم وهذه مشكله
فالنبي صلى الله عليه وسلم لم يفعل ذلك لم
يبني حاره
او مباني ويجعل فيها المهاجرين ولو قال
للانصار لفعلوا ذلك ولبادروا اليه كان في
وسعه ان يجمع المهاجرين ويجعل حاره حاره
المهاجرين وحاره الانصار لكن الانسجام لا
يتم
وانما ماذا صنع صلى الله عليه وسلم
استقبل المهاجرين
واخى بين المهاجرين والانصار
فاول خمسين مهاجري اخر بينهم وبين خمسين
من عظماء الانصار كل واحد ياخذ اخوه لبيته
هذا فلان انت اخوك فلان فلان انت اخوك
فلان مهاجري وانصاري حتى ماذا حتى
يذوب هذا الحاجز الذي قد يكون في القلوب
بين المهاجرين والانصار ولذلك
جاء في صحيح البخاري ان رجلا من المهاجرين
يعني اقتتل مع رجل من الانصار
كانوا في غزوه
وانتهت المعركه
واحد من المهاجرين كان يمزح مع الانصاري
فضربه
بعارض السيف يعني مش بحد السيف بعرض السيف
وفي روايه ضرباه في اسده يعني في مؤخرته
اما مازحا او يعني متهكما
فغضب الانصاري
فقال المهاجريا للمهاجرين يعني يفزعوا لي
المهاجرين وقال الانصاري يا للانصار يعني
افزعوا لي يا انصار
فالنبي صلى الله عليه وسلم سمع هذا النداء
فقال ما بال دعوى جاهليه واين وانا بين
اظهركم
هذه دعوه جاهليه
كلمه مهاجري كلمه انصاري الانصار
المهاجرين هذه التسميه جاءت من الله
سبحانه وتعالى والسابقون الاولون من
المهاجرين والانصار هذا اعظم شرف يناله
احد الصحابه اما ان يكون مهاجري او يكون
انصاريا هذا من اعظم ما يمكن ان يتوسم به
احدهم لكن هذه الكلمه
كانت التسميه طيبه والمقصد خبيث
هذا يعني يفزعوا لي يا مهاجرين كنت على
الحق ولا ما كنت على الحق
وافزعوا لي يا انصار
لانصار مثل مثلكم كنت على الحق او ما كنت
على الحق هذه دعوه جاهليه
فقال صلى الله عليه وسلم دعوها فانها
منتنه ما تحكوا هيك هذا الكلام منتن
فالالفاظ الطيبه اذا طاغت عن حدها واصبحت
معولا لهدم الاخوه الاسلاميه فانها تكون
حينئذ في ذاك المقام محرما
يعني مثلا يجوز للواحد انه يكون شافعي
وهذا مذهبه
والعلماء
ما زالوا ولا يزال
يتعرفون على مذاهب
العلماء الاخرين ويعرفون العلماء على
مذاهبهم بماذا بهذا التعريف هذا شافعي او
حنفي او مالك او
حنبلي او ظاهري او ما شابه ذلك هذه
هذه التسميه مباحه في اصلها
لكن تكون ماذا تكون محرمه
اذا كانت معولا
لهدم الاخوه الاسلاميه اذا كانت اذا كانت
هذه التسميه ميزانا
للحب والبغض والولاء والبراء يعني انسان
مهما كان فيه من خير او من حق او ما شابه
ذلك اذا كان حنفي فهذا لا اختلط به وهذا
اذا كان شافعيا مهما كان معه من خبث او
بدعه او ما شابه ذلك فهو مقبول لديه هذا
هو التحزب الذي انحرف به
السابقون السابقون من الديانات الاخرى
الله عز وجل يقول
الذين فرقوا دينهم
وكانوا شيعا
لست منهم في شيء هكذا يقول
وفي قراءه الذين فارقوا دينهم وكانوا شيعا
للدلاله على ان هذا التحزب والتفرق هو عين
ماذا الفراق بينه وبين الجاده
على كل حال النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
بوحي الله وفي رعايه الله
جعل عمليه المؤاخاه بين المهاجرين
والانصار يقول الامام
ابن القيم رحمه الله فصل في بناء المسجد
قال الزهري بركت ناقته صلى الله عليه وسلم
عند موضع مسجده وهو يومئذ يصلي فيه رجال
من المسلمين وكان مربدا ليتيمين من حجر
اسعد ابن زراره فساومه ما فيه رسول الله
صلى الله عليه وسلم فقال
بل نهبه لك فابى حتى ابتاعه منهما بعشره
دنانير وكان جدارا ليس له سقف
وقبلته الى بيت المقدس وكان يصلي فيه
ويجمع اسعد ابن زراره قبل مقدم رسول الله
صلى الله عليه وسلم وكان فيه شجر غرقد
ونخل وقبور للمشركين فامر رسول الله صلى
الله عليه وسلم بالقبور فنبشت وبالنخل
والشجر فقطع
صفت في قبله المسجد
وجعل طوله مما يلي القبله 100 ذراع الى
المؤخره الى المؤخره وفي الجانبين مثل ذلك
او دونه وجعل اساسه قريبا من ثلاثه اذرع
ثم بنوه باللبن ورسول الله صلى الله عليه
وسلم يبني معهم وينقل اللبن
والحجاره بنفسه ويقول اللهم لا عيش الا
عيش الاخره فاغفر للانصار والمهاجره وكان
يقول هذا الحمال لا حمال خيبر هذا ابر
ربنا واطهر
وجعلوا يرتجزون وهم ينقلون اللبن
وجعل بعضهم يقول في
رجزه لان قعدنا والرسول يعملوا لذاك منا
العمل المضلل
وجعل قبلته الى بيت المقدس وجعل له ثلاثه
ابواب بابا في مؤخره وبابا يقال له باب
الرحمه والباب الذي يدخل منه رسول الله
صلى الله عليه وسلم وجعل عمده الجذوع
وسقفه الجريد وقيل له الا تسقفه
فقال لا عريشك عريش موسى يقول لا عريش
كعريش موسى يعني متواضع
وبنى بيوتا الى جانبه بيوت ازواجه باللبن
وسقفها بالجذوع والجريد فلما فرغ من
البناء بنى بعائشه في البيت الذي بناه لها
شرقي المسجد
وجعل لسوده بيتا اخر فهو بنى بعائشه رضي
الله عنها
عندما تم بناء المسجد
وحجر نسائه ثم اخى بين المهاجرين والانصار
وكانوا سبعين رجلا
نصفهم من المهاجرين ونصفهم من الانصار على
المواساه
نصفهم من المهاجرين يعني 35 مهاجري و35
انصاري هذول بدايه الدوله
هل كان ثم اكثر من 35 مهاجرين نعم هل كان
هناك اكثر من 35 انصاري طبعا لكن
ابرز واعظم
المهاجرين
انتبه النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم وركز على
ان
يكون مع ابرز واشراف الانصار حتى تتم
المؤاخاه الحقيقيه
والمؤاخاه هذه كانت شديده جدا حتى كان في
بدايه الاسلام في المدينه كانت الوراثه
للاخ يعني كان الانصاري الذي
اخى بينه النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم وبين
المهاجرين له في الورثه
يرثون بعض
لماذا
هذا يعني تمام ما في فرق بينه وبين
النسب ابدا ما في فرق بينه وبين النسب
هذه العمليه
جعلت
المهاجرين والانصار لهم اخوه شديده لا
تزعزعها المشاكل
والمنافقون
المنافقين
بدوروا على المشاكل النبي صلى الله عليه
وسلم اول ما جاء الى المدينه طبعا ثم اناس
في المدينه كانوا اشراف
كانوا اشراف الانصار كانوا اشراف اليهود
كانوا
فلما جاء النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم بنوره
انغمر نور هؤلاء
فبعضهم حقد
بعضهم حققت مثل ما حصل مع قارون وموسى
عليه السلام نفس العمليه وفرعون وموسى نفس
العمليه
لانه يريد هو ماذا ان يكون الزعيم الاكبر
الذي يصدر عن رايه ويفعل بقوله وامره دون
سؤال ما هي مساله انه خلينا نسال الرسول
بجوز نعمل لا هو بده يبقى الكبير يحكي
الكلمه وفش حدا اكبر منه لا يحكم كتاب
الله ولا يحكم رسول الله
فلما كانت المساله هكذا
بعد هؤلاء الحاقدين
تدعى فيه شغله في
التحريش بين المسلمين
وكان اكبر منفذ لهذا
اكبر منفذ لهذا التحريش هو ماذا الفجوه
بين
المهاجرين والانصار فالنبي صلى الله عليه
وسلم سد هذه الفجوه وبادر الى ذلك حتى لا
يدع
لا يدع مجالا بين الاخوان المسلمين
واعدائهم من المنافقين الذين يسموهم في
اللغه الحديثه الطابور الخامس
يقول ثم اخى بين المهاجرين والانصار
وكانوا تسعين عفوا وكانوا تسعين رجلا يعني
مهاجري و45 انصاري انا قلت 70 لا غلط
قريتها زاغت عيني وكانوا تسعين رجلا نصفهم
من المهاجرين ونصفهم من الانصار على
المواساه على المواسى
المواسى
هذه الكلمه ماخوذه من السواء
التسويه فهي مواساه والمواساه
هي ان تجعل ما لك لاخيك
على السواء
على السواء هذه هي المواساه يعني ما لك لي
وما لي لك انا واياك زي بعض في النصيب في
المال او البيت او ما شابه ذلك
فاخذ بينهم مش بس والله خذوا عندك يا فلان
وقعدوا في
الصالون يعني يومين ثلاثه عبين ما يلاقي
محل لا بعض هؤلاء كانوا اغنياء اثريه من
المهاجرين
كادر هو يبني بيت لحاله ويسكن لحاله لكن
النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم اخ بينه
ومش بس ساكن وعابر سبيل لا هذا اخوك لك
له مالك وعليك ما عليه هكذا هذه اصل
الاخوه الشرعيه التي يقول النبي صلى الله
عليه وسلم في حديثه
سبع
سبع يظلهم الله في ظله يوم لا ظل الا ظله
وفي قوله صلى الله عليه وسلم
ثلاث ثلاث من كنا فيه وجد بهن حلاوه
الايمان
ان ومنها ان يحب المراه لا يحبه الا لله
وفي مسند احمد عن ابي هريره
ينادى يوم القيامه
ينادي الله سبحانه وتعالى يوم القيامه اين
المتحابين فيا اليوم اظلهم في ظل
وفي روايه في ظل العرش
وعلى كل حال
يقول
وكانوا تسعين رجلا نصفهم من نصفهم من
المهاجرين ونصف من الانصار على المواساه
ويتوارثون بعد الموت الى وقعه بدر وقعت
بدر كانت في السنه الثانيه يعني قعدوا
سنتين على هذه الحال
يعني صار المهاجر في
يتخلل بيت الانصاري وهو منهم
والعكس صحيح
فكانوا يتوارثون فيما بينهم
حتى كانت وقعت بدر فلما نزلت اخر ايه في
سوره الانفال واولو الارحام بعضهم اولى
ببعض نسخ هذا الحكم
وبقي ما بقي من المؤاخاه انما الذي نسخ
فقط هذه وهي مساله
التوارث بين الانصار والمهاجري
انساجم القوم
واتلائموا والحمد لله والان اعاد الله
سبحانه وتعالى الامر الى نصابه
وقالوا الارحام بعضهم اولى ببعض في كتاب
الله
يقول رد التوارث الى الرحم وقيل انه اخى
بين المهاجرين ثانيه واتخذ عليا اخا
هذا قول لاحظوا
اللفظ هنا لفظ
الشيخ دقيق
يقول وقيل
وقيل ايش يعني قيل يعني هذا رايي لكن لا
اتبناه
المؤلف في الغالب العلماء اذا نقلوا القول
وفي بدايه الامر جزم فقال ثم اخى بين
المهاجرين والانصار وبعدين قال وقيل انه
اخى بين المهاجرين ثانيه
هذا اللفظ يدل على ان المؤلف لا يتبنى هذا
الراي ولا يراه
وانما يضعفه يقول وقيل انه اخى بين
المهاجرين ثانيه واتخذ عليا اخا والاول
اثبت ولو كان ذلك لكان احق الناس باخوته
الصديق الذي قال فيه لو كنت متخذا من امه
خليلا لاتخذت ابو بكر خليله ولكن اخي
وصاحبي
يعني القصه انه اخر بين المهاجرين وجعل
المؤاخاه بين نفسي وبين علي بن ابي طالب
رضي الله عنه هذه روايه لا تثبت
ليست صحيحه لا تثبت وضعفها المؤلف والظاهر
ان هذه جاءت من بعض المغالين في علي بن
ابي طالب رضي الله عنه من
المشيعه والروافض
يريدون ان يقولوا وان يزعموا ان عليا رضي
الله عنه هو افضل الصحابه على الاطلاق وهو
افضل من ابي بكر وعمر وهو احق بالخلاف من
ابي بكر وعمر والى اخره وهذا الكلام كله
باطل تبطله الروايات الكثيره المتواتره
والايات القاطعه
بعدم صحه هذا الكلام علي بن ابي طالب رضي
الله عنه من افاضل علماء وشجعان وفرسان
الصحابه وهو ابن
ابن عم رسول الله صلى الله عليه وسلم وهو
فارس فارس قريش وهو ليث حرب رسول الله صلى
الله عليه وسلم على اعدائه وهو من العلماء
والعظماء الاحبار ومن قله الرجال الذين
ومن قليل الرجال الذين
جمعوا بين امامه الحديد وامامه الكتاب
وهو الخليفه الرابع رضي الله عنه
لكن
المغالاه في انه نقول لا هو افضل من كل
الصحابه هو حتى افضل من ابو بكر هو حتى
افضل بعضهم غالي في المساله هاي حتى جعلوه
افضل من الرسول نفسه صلى الله عليه وسلم
ولا تستعجبوا لان البدعه هكذا البدعه
دائما تبتدا يسيره الناس يقولوا يعني شو
المشكله مش قصه
وبعدين يبنى على هذه البدعه حتى تصبح ماذا
مخرجه لاصحابها عن الاسلام وعن الصراط
السوي هكذا البدعه
الشرك عباده الاصنام هي بدعه
ولا لا عباده الاصنام هي بدعه
ابتدعاها بعض الجهال من الامم السالفه
وكان هذا عن حسن قصد الشرك بالله عباده
الاصنام كانت عن حسن قصد كيف كانوا يقولون
احنا عنا ذنوب واحنا مقصرين واحنا واحنا
وهذولا الجماعه اصحاب العلم واصحاب الامر
بالمعروف والنهي عن المنكر هذول اولياء
خلينا نصاحبهم عشان مثل الجليس الصالح
والجليس السوء كحامل المسك والى اخره
وبعدين ابتدا ويغالوا في هذول الناس ادعي
لي يا فلان واذا عنده مصيبه يجي عنده
بالله ادعي لي دعاء واحسن وبعدين لما مات
برضو
صاروا حتى صاروا يعبدونه من دون الله
لماذا قالوا في اصل شركهم قالوا ما نعبدهم
الا ليقربون الى الله زلفه هذه البدعه
ابتدات بدعه
لذلك العلماء يقولون البدعه بريد الكفر
تعرفون البريد البريد يعني مش البريد
الرسائل البريد المقصود به
الفرس الجواد السريع الذي كان اذا في
مساله ملحه الامير بده يوصلها للجيش ولا
يودي البريد ما عنده حدا بيسافر وبيقطع
المسافات البعيده على عده خيول فكان عندهم
خط
وهذا الخط في عليه مواقف وفي كل موقف في
فرس جواد سريع يتحمل فكان يسافر ويوصل
للثاني وحط الاول عشان يستمر المساله اللي
بدها تقعد عشره ايام او اسبوعين عشان تصل
مع البريد تصل في يومين ثلاثه هذا هو
البريد فالعلماء يقولون البدعه بريد الكفر
احنا اصل البدعه مشتق من الكفر
ام لهم شركاء شرعوا لهم من الدين ما لم
ياذن به الله هكذا يقول الله
على كل حال الابتداع في الدين هكذا يبتدا
يبتدئ يراه العلماء والعلماء يعظمون
يقولون لا تفعل هذا
هذه ليست من السنه هذا يا شيخ شو المشكله
يعني احنا بدنا نقرا قران ايوه اقرا قران
لكن اقراه كما جاء عن النبي صلى الله عليه
وسلم
والبدعه
دائما النيه حسنه
النيه حسنه لكن النيه الحسنه لا تبرر
مخالفه الرسول صلى الله عليه وسلم
وفي مثل هذا
جاء مثلا رجل الى الامام مالك رحمه الله
وساء له عن
ميقات اهل المدينه
يعني للحج للاحرام
فذكر له الامام مالك رحمه الله مكان
الميقات مكان الاحرام
فقال انا اريد
ان احرم من القبر
القبر الرسول صلى الله عليه وسلم
قال له لا تفعل
فقال انما هي
انما هي
مسافه رميه حجر يعني شو الفرق
قليله
بنزيدها شو المشكله
اي يعذبني الله على امتار فقال لا يعذبك
الله على مخالفه الرسول صلى الله عليه
وسلم
واحد بيجي وبيقترح طريقه جديده انه يذكر
يذكر ربنا فيها يقترح طريقه جديده انه
يفسر القران يقترح طريقه جديده انه يتقرب
الى الله
وشاكلها حسن في الخارج
فهيستحسنها الناس
العلماء يقولون لا تفعلوا
فالناس يقولون
هؤلاء
ينهون عن الصلاه ينهون عن الصلاه على
الرسول ينهون عن هذا الكلام باطل انه لم
ياتي عن الصلاه على الرسول ولا على الصلاه
وانما جاء النهي عن ماذا عن هذه الكيفيه
من الكيفيه من الشرع
والناس لما
ابتداوا
ابتداوا يتفلتوا من علمائهم ويسيئوا الظن
بعلمائهم ضلوا وتنظر للدنيا اليوم فش
اثنين متفقين
والسبب السبب ان الناس انحلوا عن علمائهم
علماؤهم ورثه الانبياء
والمسلمين لما اختلطوا بالكفار النصارى
مثلا واليهود
ابن شيخ الاسلام رحمه الله يقول
كان اسوا الامم الماضيه اسوا الناس فيهم
علمائهم
كيف هذا الله عز وجل لم ياتمن علماء بني
اسرائيل
كان كلما هلك نبي يبعث نبي ليش لانه
علمائهم كانوا لا يؤتمنوا
لانه غير مامنين
لذلك حرف الكلم عن بعض مواضعه وحرفوا
الكلمه عن مواضعه ومن بعد مواضعه
وكتبوا الكتاب بايديهم وقالوا هذا من عند
الله واشتروا به ثمنا قليلا
يقول شيخ الاسلام رحمه الله
كان شرار الامم السالفه علماؤهم
وخيار هذه الامه علمائهم
لان النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم لم يخلف
نبيا بني اسرائيل كل ما مات نبي يطلع نبي
جاء في الصحيحين يقول صلى الله عليه وسلم
كانت بنو اسرائيل تسوسهم الانبياء كلما
هلك نبي
بعث الله
كلما هلك نبي خلفه نبي
وكان الله عز وجل لم ياتم من بني اسرائيل
علماء بني اسرائيل على رسالته كان الوحي
متصل
لكن هذه الامه صارت العكس
يقول صلى الله عليه وسلم
الا وان العلماء ورثه الانبياء
العلماء في هذه الامه
اخذوا محل الانبياء في الامم السابقه شرف
عظيم لذلك راوي بن عبد البابار في فضل
العلم
يحمل هذا العلم من كل خلف عدوله
يعني احسن كل طبقه من الناس يحمل هذا
العلم
الناس لما اختلطوا بالكفار واختلطوا
بالمسلمين اختلطوا باهل الكتاب من النصارى
واليهود وراءوا الخبث الموجود عند علماء
اليهود والنصارى ظنوا نفس الشيء في ايش في
علماء المسلمين وتجد هذا اليوم وانتشر جدا
لا يتكلم نبيه الا ويقوم عليه الناس ما
يتكلم عالم الا ويقوم عليه كل الناس
وكلك شوف هذولا متخلفين ومش عارف ايش
وهذول الناس عايشين في كوكب اخر وهذول
العلماء عايشين في دنيا اخرى وهذول
العلماء وكلام
وبعدين يشك يشكك في ايش في فهم العلماء
فكل واحد الحين صار عنده صحيح البخاري بحط
رجل على رجل وبقعد يتصفح
يقول لك هذا الحديث ما اظن لا اظن هذا
الحديث قال له رسول الله هكذا
وبعدين يقول هذا الحديث اكيد صحيح انا
متاكد كانه عرف الرسول وعاش معه وسكن معه
وعارف شو بيقول وشو ما بيكون
وكان الامام البخاري يعني دراويش انسان بس
هيك لملم الحكي من هان ومن هان وحطه في
التاب والناس بس كبلوه لانه الناس كانوا
متحجرين زمان ومتخلفين لكن الان الناس
اصبحوا علماء كلام باطل كلام معكوس منكوس
هذا الكلام غلط الناس كل ما ابتعدوا عن
عهد النبوه دخلوا في الظلمه
وبتعدوا عن العلم
واقتربوا من التخلف الحقيقي
وكل ما اقترب الجيل من عهد الرسول صلى
الله عليه وسلم كل مكان النور والعلم
والوحي
على كل حال هذه مساله
ذكرناها لان الخطا منتشر فيها ان شاء الله
نكتفي بهذا القدر وجزاكم الله خيرا والله
اعلم وصلى الله وسلم على نبينا محمد وعلى
اله واصحابه اجمعين بارك